(dramatic piano music)
- [Ahmad] Every time I
dance, I try to do my best
and I give the most because
living in the war taught me
maybe this time, it will
be the last dance for you.
Maybe you will be killed in a bomb
or a bullet or something
when you leave the studio.
So every time I would give my best
and live it to the most.
- [Narrator] Ahmad Joudeh
was born in the Yarmouk Camp,
a refugee camp for Palestinians in Syria.
Despite his tumultuous surroundings,
he found escape in a hobby
uncommon in his culture.
- I saw dance for the first time
when I was a child-8 years old,
'cause I was fascinated by their movements
and by the music that they are moving on.
I learned how to dance
through videos on YouTube,
and I was doing this every
day in my room secretly
because dancing in my
culture, especially for a man,
it's something to be ashamed of.
My life was in danger when I was in Syria
because I was a dancer
and that's because of the extremist people
who came into our country
and then I start to
receive all these messages
or phone calls or those kind of things
that telling me they want to cut my head,
and that's why I had my
tattoo dance or die on my neck
'cause I carry my life on my neck.
And if they would've killed me,
I wanted it to be the last
thing they can see from me,
so it's dance or die.
- [Narrator] While in Syria,
Ahmad went on to receive
formal dance training
and would post videos of his dancing
and was eventually discovered
by a documentary filmmaker
from Holland who wanted to tell his story.
The film was seen by the
Dutch National Ballet,
who offered him a scholarship.
He has since gone on to
perform all over Europe.
- We are here in Kilden Theater
talking about social media.
In this production, I'm acting myself
because social media played
the most important role
in saving my life in my story;
because through social media, I was seen
and I was rescued.
(playful orchestral music)
What made me keep dancing
and keep on doing what am
I doing even 'til today
because I believe the
artist has the same duty
like the soldier to fight for his country
and the artist can fight for culture
and for art and for history.
And if we don't have art and
culture in our countries,
what are we fighting for?
Away from dance, I am
nothing, and I have nothing.
All I have is dance, and
all I am is the dancer.
Then maybe in the far future,
sometimes I see myself sitting in a chair
as an old man in theater in Syria
directing the Syrian National
Ballet that I will find,
so I hope this dream will come true.
(tones pinging)